إنها حقيقة من حقائق الحياة أن المنتجات الطازجة
تفسد في نهاية المطاف في جميع أنحاء العالم ، حيث يفسد ثلث الطعام بشكل أسرع
مما يمكننا استهلاكه
، أي ما يقدر بنحو 1.3 مليار طن من
الطعام المهدر كل عام ، ولكن ماذا لو
كانت هناك طريقة آمنة لصنع المنتجات الطازجة
تدوم لفترة أطول ، لذا فإن
عمرهما 70 يومًا و 70 يومًا جالسين في
درجة حرارة الغرفة ، أعني مثل هذا
الذي سأجعله في عصير الليمون ، نعم هذا غير
معالج ويتم معالجته بعد 70
يومًا.
يدخل الأكسجين
ويبدأ طعامك في
الظهور على هذا النحو ، ولكن في Appeal Sciences قاموا بتطوير طبقة واقية خاصة تعمل على إبطاء عملية التعفن مما يزيد من العمر الافتراضي للمنتجات الطازجة من الليمون إلى الأفوكادو والنتيجة هي أننا نبني هذا
مناخ محلي محسّن قليلاً داخل
كل قطعة فردية من المنتجات والتي
تبقى بعد ذلك مع المنتج طوال
سلسلة التوريد بأكملها ، يمكننا
مضاعفة العمر الافتراضي للأفوكادو  د الحمضيات
وعشرات الفئات الأخرى لدينا
في مختبرنا القدرة على مضاعفة
مدة الصلاحية ثلاث مرات ، وفي النهاية
نقترب من تمديد 4 أضعاف للمنتجات
على عكس العديد من العوامل الكيميائية المستخدمة
للحفاظ على المنتجات الطازجة اليوم.
هل تعتقد أن
هناك حاجزًا أو سيتردد الناس
في تناول المنتجات التي يتم
معالجتها بمنتجك ، هل تعتقد أن
الناس سيربطونها بالمبيدات الحشرية
والأشياء الأخرى التي يحاول الناس
الابتعاد عنها لأننا لا نستخدم أي شيء في
منطقتنا  المنتجات التي لا توجد في كل
قضمة واحدة من الفاكهة والخضروات
تأكلها كل يوم حتى تتمكن من وضع
منتجك ، دعنا نقول تفاحة عضوية
ولا يتغير هذا صحيحًا ،
فهذا يبقى عضويًا مع طلبات الاستئناف
يمكن للمزارعين حصادهم  إنتاج أقرب
إلى وقت نضجها ، مما يؤدي إلى
نتائج صحية ولذيذة ، يمكننا السماح
لشركائنا بحصاد تلك الطماطم في وقت أقرب
إلى ذروة النضج بحيث بحلول الوقت الذي تصل فيه
في رف المتجر ، لا يزال في
حالة جيدة
طعمه مر
في سلطتنا المليئة بالمغذيات مع
التكنولوجيا الفريدة من نوعها حقًا في
أيديهم التي جذبت سبعين
مليون دولار في شكل تمويل جديد ولديها
منتجات في أكثر من 200 متجر أمريكي  لذلك
هذا هو أحد العناصر التي لا
تراها عادةً على الرف ، نعم
هذه بالضبط هي خطوط الكافيار ، إنها
شكل من أشكال الحمضيات الدقيقة ، وعادةً
ما يكون عمرها الافتراضي حوالي خمسة إلى سبعة أيام
ومع تقنيتنا يمكننا ذلك
حملهم على الاقتراب من حوالي 21 يومًا ،
كان هذا أول منتج
أطلقناه تجاريًا بعد
نداء متاجر البقالة يحاول إحداث
تأثير على سلاسل الإمداد الغذائي في
البلدان النامية حيث يمكن فقد ما يصل إلى 80٪ من
الطعام جزئيًا بسبب نقص
التبريد  لدينا فريق يعمل
في كينيا على مدار العام ونقوم برحلات منتظمة
إلى نيجيريا للقيام
بتطوير المنتجات في الكسافا وضمن
فئة الطماطم وكيف
استجابوا لها يمكننا إضافة حوالي خمسة
إلى سبعة أيام من العمر الافتراضي للمانجو
بدون تبريد مما يعني
الفرق بين التعفن على
جانب الطريق أو بيعها بعشرة أضعاف
الكمية داخل وسط المدينة ، وعلينا أن نوفر
لك بعض المنتجات الجذابة
حتى نتمكن من القيام بذلك
تعد تكاليف البنية التحتية للطماطم واحدة من
أعلى التكاليف التي يمكن أن تتحملها الدولة
، ومن ثم تعرف ما إذا كان بإمكانك تسليم
كيس من المواد الخاصة بنا وهي
خفيفة الوزن ومنخفضة التكلفة لتوزيعها
على منطقة نائية حيث
يمكن تطبيقها بعد ذلك ولديك الآن
أسبوع إضافي لنقل هذا المنتج بدون
تبريد لديه فرصة
أن يكون تحويليًا حقًا